veamos si podemos encontrar el límite
cuando x tiende a -1 de x1 entre la raíz
cuadrada de x + 5 ya esto le quitamos 2
y bueno tal vez nuestra primera reacción
podría ser bien vamos a usar algunas de
las propiedades de los límites para
trabajar este límite que tengo aquí y
decir esto es lo mismo que tomarme el
límite el límite cuando x tiende al
menos uno de mx1
esto a su vez dividido todo esto a su
vez dividido entre el límite cuando x 30
menos 1
de la parte de abajo que es la raíz
cuadrada de x 5 ya esto le quitamos 2 y
bueno luego podríamos decir la gráfica
de la función de igual a x1 es continua
en todos lados especialmente en x igual
a menos 1 entonces para evaluar este
límite
solamente tendríamos que evaluar esta
expresión en menos 1 así que este
numerador simplemente me quedaría como
menos uno más uno cuando hacemos esta
evaluación y ahora qué pasa con la parte
de abajo bueno en nuestro denominador la
función raíz de x más 5 menos 2 no es
continua en todos lados pero si es
continua en x igual a menos 1 entonces
podemos hacer lo mismo podemos
simplemente sustituir el valor de menos
1 y me quedaría la raíz cuadrada
menos 15 menos uno más
5 - 2 muy bien ahora aquí es igual todo
esto bueno el numerador tendríamos menos
uno más uno lo cual es simplemente cero
y en el denominador tendríamos menos 154
la raíz principal de 42 menos 2 bueno
también me dan 0 entonces tenemos la
forma 0 sobre 0
ahora cuando tú ves esto podría estar
tentado a rendirte decir hay un cero en
el denominador y tal vez este límite no
existe ya terminé aquí o qué hago pero
ojo si arriba tienes algo distinto de
cero en el numerador estás obteniendo un
valor diferente de cero que a su vez
estaría dividido el 30 en este caso si
tendríamos algo indefinido en su límite
no existirían pero cuando tienes esta
forma cero entre cero esto es una forma
indeterminada no significa
necesariamente que su límite no existe y
como veremos en este vídeo y en algunos
próximos
hay algunas herramientas a nuestra
disposición para abordar este tipo de
casos y hoy vamos a ver una de esas
herramientas la herramienta que vamos a
ver es otra manera de escribir esta
expresión que tengo aquí para así poder
evaluar este límite sin obtener cero
entre cero y lo que vamos a hacer es
básicamente tomar esta expresión que
tengo aquí y primero ponerle un nombre
vamos a decir que gtx es esto que tengo
aquí
gx es la función déjame ponerlo es la
función x + 1
esto a su vez dividido dividido entre la
raíz de x 5 - 2
y la forma en la que estoy definiendo a
gtx es para que te des cuenta de una
manera más clara que es una función y
por lo tanto podemos manipularla y
pensar en funciones similares y lo que
queremos encontrar es el límite cuando x
tienda menos 1 deje de x ahora la
técnica que vamos a usar es cuando
tienen una forma indeterminada y si
tienen una raíz cuadrada en cualquiera
ya sea en el denominador o en el
numerador entonces puede ayudarnos
bastante deshacernos de esa raíz
cuadrada y esto a menudo es llamado
racionalizar la expresión en este caso
tienen una raíz cuadrada en el
denominador entonces podemos
racionalizar el denominador y la manera
en la que lo haríamos es aprovechando
nuestro conocimiento de la diferencia de
cuadrados porque nosotros sabemos que si
tomamos aa + b
a esto lo multiplicamos a su vez por a
menos bueno de la multiplicación de
estos dos obtengo a cuadrado menos b
cuadrada y seguramente lo aprendiste en
álgebra hace algún tiempo o en este caso
si tenemos no sé la raíz cuadrada de a
esto más b ya esto lo multiplicamos por
la raíz cuadrada de a menos b bueno pues
en este caso que me quedaría me quedaría
bueno aquí tengo la raíz cuadrada de am
al cuadrado lo cual es simplemente am y
después tengo el cuadrado el segundo lo
cual sería menos el cuadrada así que
vamos a intentar usar esta información
que tengo aquí para poder racionalizar
esta expresión y para eso qué te parece
si multiplicamos a esta expresión que
tengo aquí déjame ponerlo quiero
multiplicar a esta expresión que tengo
aquí por quién bueno voy a multiplicar
la parte de abajo por
la raíz cuadrada de x 5 + 2 porque aquí
tenemos menos 2 y ahora necesitamos más
2 para poder llegar a algo de este
estilo entonces voy a multiplicar abajo
por la raíz cuadrada de x +
5 y esto más 2 muy bien y el numerador
lo voy a multiplicar por lo mismo porque
no queremos cambiar el valor de la
expresión
entonces si pongo aquí la raíz cuadrada
de x más 5 ok ya esto le sumamos 2
observa que lo que estoy haciendo es
multiplicar por 1 porque esto de aquí es
1 por lo tanto si tenemos esta expresión
dividida entre la misma expresión va a
ser 1 al multiplicarlo por esto no se
afecta pero ahora sí que me quedaría de
multiplicar estos dos y entonces nos
quedaría que esto es igual a bueno
arriba tengo x + 1 que multiplica a su
vez a esto que tengo aquí que es la raíz
x 5 ok ya esto le sumamos 2 y en la
parte de abajo que me va a quedar bueno
si observas lo que me va a quedar es lo
siguiente siguiendo esta lógica de aquí
me queda am que es esta expresión que
tengo aquí sin la raíz x más 5 ya esto
le quitamos 4 ahora bien x 5 menos 4
esto es lo mismo que x + 1 entonces a
esto lo podemos dividir en 3 x 1 y
seguramente te va a saltar que aquí
tenemos a x + 1 multiplicando ya x + 1
dividiendo así que estos dos los puedo
cancelar y me quedaría simplemente con
la raíz de x + 5
esto a su vez le sumamos 2
ahora bien algunos de ustedes podrían
estarse sintiendo un poco perdidos y
estarían en lo correcto su sentido común
pensaría esto de aquí y esto de aquí es
en definitiva lo mismo que esto de aquí
es decir esta expresión antes de
cancelar el x + 1 y la respuesta es que
en la forma en la que lo escribí no es
exactamente lo mismo es exactamente lo
mismo en todos lados excepto en x igual
a menos 1 esta cosa de aquí está
definida en x igual a menos 1 mientras
que esto de aquí no está definida en x
igual a menos 1 al igual que en 7 x 7 x
no obtiene un buen resultado cuando
evaluamos a x con el valor de menos 1
así que para quitarnos este problema y
con el fin de que sean exactamente las
mismas funciones tenemos que decir que
funcionan para todas x que no sea x
igual a menos 1
para x distinta de menos 1
ahora esto de aquí es una versión
reducida de gx para cualquier entrada de
x en la que gtx esté definida esto va a
darles la misma salida y ahora es
exactamente el mismo dominio porque
hemos puesto esta restricción de aquí y
bueno tal vez ahora podrían decir cómo
nos ayuda a esto y bueno tal vez es hora
de pensar cómo nos va a ayudar esto ya
que tenemos que encontrar el límite
cuando x es igual a menos 1 e incluso
aquí tuve que poner esta restricción de
que x no puede ser igual a menos 1
entonces como planteamos este límite
bien por suerte sabemos que si tomamos
otra función que voy a llamar f x y
vamos a definir a esta función
efe de x f x como y me voy a tomar a
esta función f x como la raíz
x + 5
+ 2 es decir la misma función solamente
que si la restricción para todas las x
distintas de menos 1 y entonces por
suerte sabemos que en fx
efe x esto es igual a gdx ag de x
si contamos esta restricción para para
todas x todas x distinta de menos 1
ahora bien ya que fx tiene esa
restricción
entonces para cualquier otro valor se
cumple esta igualdad eso quiere decir
que el límite cuando x tiende a menos 1
de esta función efe x va a ser igual al
límite cuando x tiende a menos 1 de esta
función g de x
que por supuesto recuerda que esto es lo
que queremos encontrar es el principio
del problema pero ahora aquí podemos
usar a fx porque solamente en x igual a
menos 1 no son iguales si fueras a
gráfica gtx tendrá la misma gráfica que
fx excepto que tiene un punto
discontinuo en x igual a menos 1
entonces cuál es este límite de fx o
podríamos decir
el límite cuando x tiende a menos uno de
estos de aquí de la raíz de x + 5
ya esto le sumamos dos ahora bien esta
expresión de kim es continua en x igual
a menos 1 así que podemos evaluarla en
ese valor y obtendríamos lo siguiente
este límite va a ser igual a la raíz voy
a sustituir a x por menos 1 me va a
quedar menos 1 + 5 + 2 ahora am esto de
aquí es la raíz cuadrada de 4 y la raíz
principal de 4 es 2 así que esto de aquí
me quedaría exactamente igual que 4 y
qué creés éste es el límite que
estábamos buscando el límite de gtx
porque al ser el límite de fx también es
el límite deje de x y ya está aunque si
este paso último que hice no tiene mucho
sentido para ti lo puedes pensar también
de una manera visual si dibujo por aquí
unos ejes déjame dibujar por acá un par
de ejes este voy a decir qué
en mi eje game y por aquí me tomo mi eje
x supongamos que es este de aquí déjame
ponerlo este es mi eje y este es mi eje
x entonces esta función
fx se va a ver más o menos así se va a
ver más o menos así más o menos así es
como esta función que tengo aquí pero si
ahora te fijas en gdx es exactamente
igual que esta función solamente que
tienes un hueco en x igual a menos 1 así
que déjame ponerlo con este color tienes
esta misma función solamente que aquí
tienes un hueco y la función sigue
exactamente igual mientras que en fx no
tendríamos este hueco entonces si estás
tratando de encontrar el límite me
parece completamente razonable usar a
efe de x que sí tiene este valor
recuerda
fx si tiene este valor
vamos a usar a esa función para ver
dónde caería este punto de aquí en x
igual a menos 1 vamos a usar
fx para rellenar este hueco en x igual a
menos 1 y bueno espero que este ejemplo
gráfico te haya ayudado un poco para
entender que es lo que está pasando con
estos dos límites y si no te ayuda mucho
y te confunden mejor ignorarlo